well we had some conversations as a
staff team on Tuesday and in which
Camilla told us that there was a
possibility that this might happen and
so as a result of that we began taking
precautions to think about our most
vulnerable young people and children and
think about what we could possibly do if
that were to come to fruition I know
that all of the staff team particularly
those who work in the senior level have
been working right up until the last
minute to try and find some way forward
and so we had the confirmation at around
5pm yesterday from from what Camilla
Batman girl he was seeing and from the
conversations you've had with with other
senior staff was this predicated for
this closure predicated on financial
grounds was it simply because there was
a lack of funding I think that it was as
Camilla said in the report and more
complicated situation than that I think
ultimately there have been a whole range
of damaging headlines recently and that
made it very difficult for us to
fundraise and so I think in terms of
sustainability anyway we knew that in
order to continue working at the level
of intensity that we were working with
the level of need that we were working
with we needed more secure funding and
so then these headlines which came out
just further destabilized things what
did what do you make of the charge that
has been laid at the door of the chief
executive the former chief executive the
kids company that she was a fantastic
fundraiser that she was able to get the
great and good to dip deep into their
pockets but there were some structural
issues with the charity which perhaps
meant money wasn't used as efficiently
as possible well I think that I think
the first pots very true she wasn't
amazing fundraiser but I also think that
kids company was a unique organization
we operated with very complex children
and young people with children and other
and young people that other agencies
struggled to engage with and with
children and young and young people in
crisis situations so on a daily basis we
would have people self referring to our
doors and in extreme situations
homelessness
extreme danger real huge levels of
poverty and I think that when when
you're working with those types of
people in those types of situations
there's sort of normal structures that
may work in other organizations on
effective because they take too long and
so I think what is fair to say is that
we we had a very different approach in a
very different model to everybody else
isn't it isn't a flip side to that coin
that when so many thousands of children
come to rely upon an organization as
kids company as they undoubtedly have it
then means that this company must be run
as efficiently as much as
straightforwardly as possible so that
are your headlines the like of which
we've seen recently they do not all
right well I think there's a difference
between efficiency and structure and I
think that kids company was incredibly
efficient and I think if you if you look
at our outcomes in terms of children and
young people and the speed with which
we've been able to provide the services
that they required of us you can see
that actually we are incredible we were
incredibly efficient I think and that
structure is something that we that we
worked on in a in a more flexible way
than other organizations and I do think
that actually it was it was very
successful we did have structures that
worked the difficulty was that we didn't
have the financial sustainability and
others didn't understand the complexity
of that flexible way of working that
there has been an allegation has been
repeated a number of times that you
might be able to deal with that there
were children who attended kids come
kids company and meetings clubs the
light who turned up on a Friday and were
handed envelopes with caching Simon
what's the truth in there well um I
think kids company provides a wraparound
service so the idea of our service was
to replicate that of a parent or
supplement that of a parent and I think
you know nobody is disputing the fact
that children received money from kids
company and food vouchers from kids
company the reality is that in the vast
majority of cases that was small amounts
of money for specific purposes and it
was given out by staff that new children
and families incredibly well and it was
done within the context of a whole range
of other wraparound services so as well
as money we were providing food we were
providing therapy
tech support we were providing key
working and I think if you think about
that in the way you would think about
parenting and pocket money and providing
basic needs whilst also providing love
and care and understanding and
constantly and informally thinking about
risk and managing risk you can see that
the kind of the safety and the context
within which money was given and I think
all of us so completely unashamed of the
fact that that went on and I think
they'll certainly thousands of children
up and down the country hoping that
other parts of the charitable sector can
step in Rachel thanks very much your
tape okay